who's God
all those Gods the stories they've been
told throughout history you said through
the spiritual traditions
what do you think that is is that us
trying to find that
common thing at the core
oh well in in many
Traditions not all
the one I was raised in so my dad was a
Protestant minister
we tend to think of God as a being
but I think that that's not right
I think the closest way to think about
God is being period not hating but being
the the very ground of being itself is
God I think that's the
the deep and and from my point of view
that's the ground of Consciousness so
the ground of conscious being is
what we might call God but but the word
God has always been you know for example
you don't believe the same God is my God
so I'm going to fight you or we'll we'll
have wars over because the being the
specific being that you call God is
different from the being that I call God
and so we fight whereas if it's
not a being but just being and you and I
share being then you and I are are not
separate and there's no reason to fight
we're both part of that one being and
and
loving you is loving myself because
we're all part of that one being
the spiritual Traditions that point to
that
I think are pointing it in a very
interesting Direction and that does seem
to
match with the mathematics of the
conscious agent stuff that I've been
working on as well that it really fits
with that although I that wasn't my goal